Chicago officials say they are preparing
to sue Empire actor jussie Smollett to
make him pay for the investigation of
his alleged hoax Smollett claims that he
was beaten January by two men who were
yelling homophobic and racial slurs
yesterday was the city's deadline for
him to reimburse more than one hundred
and thirty thousand dollars a letter
from the city says this if the amount is
not timely paid the Department of Law
may prosecute you for making a false
statement CBS News legal analyst Ricky
Clayman joins us at the table to discuss
good to see you Ricky clayman good
morning so if you're part of team Jesse
why would you pay you've said that he is
he's denied that he made a false
statement he says that he is telling the
truth so if he pays doesn't that admit
in some way that yes I lied well you're
raising exactly what his very fierce
lawyers will say which is there is no
way we are going to pay you and we are
not going to cooperate with this lawsuit
because we that is Jesse Jesse is
innocent at the same time we have to
consider Jesse's risks the city of
Chicago let's keep this in mind the
prosecution is the county of Cook County
this is the city of Chicago two
different governmental entities the city
is suing so if Jesse Smollett decides
that he's going to take this on and he's
going to go to trial and he's not gonna
pay the money he risks publicity he
risks his future in terms of his career
but really the city goes also to the
point that it's a civil case you have
depositions right well yeah point does
he have to testify yes and when will the
details of this settlement in this case
end up coming out well what happens is
ultimately it could all become public
because he when you do a depositions
that's not in a court of law but it also
is not a sealed document unless you move
to have it sealed there's no reason to
have this sealed so they can do all this
kind of discovery then if you actually
get into a court of law the entire
proceeding is public and most important
in a civil suit the burden of proof is
very low it's a preponderance of the
evidence or as I like to say
on the scales of justice it is a little
feather whereas in a criminal case it
had to be like a big rock yeah so that's
a big difference in the burden but
they're asking for the hundred and
thirty thousand dollars because they
said that's how much they spent in
resources how much they expected over
time we don't even just think about the
rest is he over - oh there's a spire on
the city of Chicago I don't see it
backfiring on the city of Chicago beyond
the fact that you're always taking into
consideration that race is a factor
within the city that there have been
protests in the city there was a protest
the other day you had the chief
Fraternal Order of Police saying they
wanted Kim Foxx the prosecutor to resign
across the street you had a lot of
people protesting the police now very
very important we have a new mayor yeah
yeah so Lori Lightfoot is coming into
office this lawsuit is being filed by
rahm emanuel he's out going there so
when you have a new mayor lori like for
it who was a former federal prosecutor
let's keep that in mind and she is very
disturbed about all of this and so she
wants to look into a better explanation
from the county prosecutor kim fox as to
why this guy got to walk just very
quickly if your justice Millette lawyers
130 thousand dollars it seems like a
small price to pay to make this go away
well problem with lawyers a well it
often is a problem with lawyers she says
as the lawyer that'll vary quite a bit
from a fee per day so I still think it's
like admitting guilt so I could see why
you acknowledging that the police work
really hard I mean why not there are
ways to create say look I'm really sorry
yes I'm really sorry that I wasted the
time of the Chicago Police who I know
are busy every day wrapping up criminals
not only am I gonna donate one hundred
thirty thousand pay you back but I'm
also gonna donate to the fallen fallen
police soldiers you know but Nora he
feels like he's the victim here that's
what he's blaming you blaming the may be
better off as we used to say pay the
nuisance value because otherwise rebel
damages attorneys fees and costs all
right Ricky Kleeman thank you so much